les tient pour autant pour nous
effectivement de montrer que le
personnel jeudi à quasiment entièrement
tout le personnel est mobilisé
effectivement pour une volonté de
poursuivre leur activité et sans le
groupe kapa qui au bout de 13 ans au 1er
avril ça fait 13 ans n'a pas démontré
une volonté de faire accroître
l'activité de cette clinique
il faut savoir quand même que nous avons
un personnel qui est extrêmement dévoués
mais qui va à combler toutes les lacunes
du manque de matériel et de fournitures
je dirais mais on ne peut pas continuer
comme ça est sincèrement pourquoi vous
avez reçus depuis s'épuise personne très
diminuée le groupe a repris par exemple
cette clinique avec 250 personnes à
l'époque
aujourd'hui nous sommes 171 sachant
qu'ils possèdent déjà des licenciements
nous avons perdu la partie maternité et
cela ira comme ça en percutant où
allons-nous demain matin laissons donc
des gens qui veulent faire avancer cette
clinique la faire avancer avec le
personnel